in this video we're going to try to get
more practice constructing lewis
diagrams and we're going to try to do
that for a cyanide anion so this is
interesting this is the first time we're
constructing a lewis diagram for an ion
so pause this video and see if you can
have a go at that
all right now let's do this together so
we've already seen in many videos the
first step is to essentially count the
total
valence electrons that we're dealing
with and the reason why we do that is to
make sure that we're allocating all the
valence electrons to help us there we
can look at a periodic table of elements
you might already know that carbon has
one two three four valence electrons in
that second shell it's in the second
period so you have four valence
electrons from carbon
nitrogen has one two three four five
valence electrons in its second shell
it's in that second period
and so the valence electrons from a
neutral carbon and a neutral nitrogen
free atom would be a total of
nine valence electrons but we are not
done yet because this is not a neutral
molecule we have a negative charge here
it is an anion has a negative one charge
and so because of that negative one we
can think about it having an extra
valence electron so
let's add a valence electron here why
did we do it because of this negative
charge so we're dealing with a total of
10
valence electrons
now the next step is to try to draw
single bonds try
single
bonds and identify a central atom now we
only have two atoms here so
really neither feels central so let me
just put a carbon and a nitrogen next to
each other here and then let me draw one
single bond so by drawing that one
single bond i have now accounted for two
valence electrons
so now i am left with eight valence
electrons and so that's the next step
allocate remaining valence electrons
allocate
valence electrons
so let me start with the more
electronegative let's try to get
nitrogen to eight already has two so
let's give it
three more lone pairs so we have two
four
six
eight
so i have just used up six of these
remaining valence electrons so minus six
so i have two left to allocate so let me
give carbon two valence electrons
like that and there i have used up all
of my all of my valence electrons
now let's see how happy everyone is
nitrogen has eight valence electrons
hanging around two four six eight but
carbon only has four two and four so
this is where we think about whether we
want to have
some extra bonds
extra bonds or higher order bonds
so how can we give carbon more valence
electrons well what we could do is we
could take some of these lone pairs
around nitrogen and then use them turn
this single covalent bond into a higher
order bond
so let's see if we were to take these
two and turn it into another covalent
bond what is going to happen let me
erase all of these and then i'll just
draw
i'll just draw another
covalent bond
so nitrogen still has eight electrons
hanging around carbon now has six so
maybe we can do that again
so let me erase these two characters
let me
erase these two characters and make
another covalent bond out of them
so
let me make
a covalent bond out of them and so now
what's going on carbon has two
four six eight valence electrons hanging
around nitrogen has two four six eight
valence electrons hanging around so this
is looking pretty good but are we done
yet
the simple answer is no we still haven't
represented this negative charge in our
lewis diagram the way that we would do
that is say hey this entire molecule you
put brackets around it has a negative
charge and now we're done we've
allocated all of our valence electrons
we have our octet rule on all of our
atoms that are not hydrogen there's no
hydrogen here and we're showing that
this indeed is an anion and now we are
done